I'm going to give you
just a brief introduction
to our Google security model.
I'll talk to you a little bit
about some of the security
products that we've
got in the works.
And I'll also talk
about compliance,
which will get into a little
bit about what we were talking
earlier about the MPAA.
So very quickly, when I'm
talking about Google Cloud,
I'm talking about our compute,
storage, and application
services.
And actually, there's
a few more things
that we've added to this slide
since I created this deck.
But for those of you that
the cloud is a new thing,
we do have our compute
engine and app engine, which
provide the compute services.
We have a variety of
storage technologies.
Probably Google's cloud storage
and also our persistent disk
capabilities are probably most
interesting to this audience.
And then we have
services like BigQuery,
which you guys can
have a lot of fun
with if you need to analyze tons
and tons of unstructured data.
Let me talk a little bit
about our security model.
And just so everybody
knows, this slide here--
we did a project about a year
and a half ago with an author
from "Wired" magazine.
And actually, there's
a really great article
that "Wired" wrote
about our data centers.
And we had the
pleasure of bringing
in-- a really great
photographer came in.
We took him through the
data centers and stuff
and got a bunch of
beautiful pictures,
so my presentation is sprinkled
with these beautiful pictures.
But they're due to two things.
One is they're really nice,
so it makes me look better.
But the other thing is
that hopefully it'll
give you a sense of a
little bit of the scale
that we're talking about
when we talk about Google.
So when you're thinking about--
not even just cloud vendors,
but when you're
thinking about service
providers in general--
the types of things
that a CIO or CSO might
take into consideration
is what's the technology?
And what is the technology
that's available to me?
Is it going to make what
I need to do easier?
Is it easy to access?
Is it easy to take advantage of?
Is it keeping pace, or
is it ahead of the curve?
And so that's a real big
consideration of why would I
go to a service provider?
Do they provide me
a better technology?
And in some instances,
the answer is yes.
In some instances,
the answer is no.
And then quite frankly, the
other reason-- the key reason--
that anybody would want to take
advantage of a public cloud
is just the scale of operation.
And can I work
with a vendor that
can provide me the
scale that I need to do
the jobs that I want to do?
And can they provide me
that scale at something
that's competitive
with doing it myself?
And then also, how
is that vendor?
Are they agile?
Can they keep up with things?
I mean, from a
security point of view,
are they keeping up with
the threat environment?
Are they doing the
right types of things?
And are they doing
this in a manner
that I don't have
to worry about it?
And can they do it
faster than my staff?
And so these are all
kinds of considerations
that we've encountered
as we've talked
to customers across a wide
variety of industries.
But these seem to be the things
that come to front of mind
as people are thinking
about taking advantage
of Google's Cloud Platform.
So the good news is-- to
answer those questions-- is
that the environment--
the Cloud Platform
that we're making
available to our customers
is the platform that
we use ourselves.
And we use this platform
to run our global search
and advertising business.
Our Google Apps
business runs on this.
Our YouTube business
runs on this.
This is the
infrastructure that we
are servicing our
hundreds of millions
of users across the globe.
And so this is the real deal.
It's not something
special we've built just
to build a Cloud Platform.
And there's some really
interesting characteristics
about it.
For us, security is
a basic principle
of what we think about, because
we do use this environment
to run our own business.
We want to protect
that business.
The search and
advertising business
is a pretty good
business for Google.
And so we have security as a
foundational thought in terms
of building our
infrastructure, and services
on top of that infrastructure.
And so some of the
things that are
kind of interesting
about it is that we
build our own servers and
our own networking equipment.
And in fact, we're one
of the top five server
manufacturers on the globe.
But those servers that we build
are exclusively for own use.
And the interesting
thing about it
is that we've got largely
a homogeneous fleet.
And you might think, oh,
well why is that important?
Well, the thing that's
really interesting
there is that that enables
us to maintain the fleet
in a couple of dimensions.
One is it's very clear to us
what the hardware and software
profile looks like on
that fleet, because it's
the same across the whole fleet.
And the other thing is
that as a result of that,
we're able to react to
things like patch management
and dealing with vulnerabilities
much, much quicker than we
would if our tens of
thousands of servers
were all different
versions of software
and different hardware
profiles and things like that.
So it's a simplicity idea
which enables us to do things
at very large scale.
We have dozens of data centers
spread around the globe that
enable us to deliver
uninterrupted services to all
of our customers.
We protect our data at rest.
We protect it in transit.
We use encryption technologies
to help us take care of that.
One of the other things that's
very interesting about Google
as a service provider, or
as just a commercial entity,
is that Google is very
interesting in that we
are disciplined in our
software development process.
And through that,
we're able to do--
we do some things
as best practices
which help us deliver
more secure services.
And things that we do there
is, for example, all services
that we build get security
and privacy design reviews
ahead of any code being written.
All code that's written
by a Google engineer
is at least reviewed
by a peer before it's
checked into our
source code repository.
And we also have a separation
between our development
operation and our actual
operations of the services.
And in fact, another
kind of fun fact
is that software services that
we deliver into production come
through a certified
build system,
and we actually validate that.
And so you can't actually go
into our production service
and patch anything unless
it goes through our
build service and is certified.
So there's no way for a
development engineer sitting
somewhere in Google to
actually insert code
into our production
systems that's
not supposed to be there.
We also take advantage of
external security verifications
and validations.
We'll run the whole
gamut of we use
commercial scanners to
scan our services looking
for vulnerabilities.
And we also will
take a step back
and we will bring in
independent security verifiers
to actually go through
source code reviews with us
and help us look at things that
we really want to truly harden
and we want to take
an unbiased look at.
As Dave was saying
earlier, we have
over 500 personnel
that are specifically
involved in security
and privacy at Google.
And many of these
people are actually
experts in their field.
And they continue to do
security research and publish.
They continue to
blog and comment
on the security industry.
And they do tons
of presentations
at a variety of
conferences, everything
from Black Hat to RSA and
everything in between.
We also have one thing that
we're really proud of--
and this is something that we
started in the industry-- is
we have our vulnerability
rewards program,
where we actually pay bounties
to security researchers
to find problems
in our software.
And for example, this
particular program
found over 700 vulnerabilities
or bugs in the Chrome browser
over the lifecycle
of its development.
And the program has
paid out over $2 million
to date to security researchers.
And oftentimes, the bounties
are $10,000, $20,000 a pop.
So you can imagine some grad
student working on his PhD
is able to live for a year
off finding a bug at Google.
I fortunately don't eat
that much ramen anymore,
so I'm a little
bit more expensive.
But some of them
really enjoy it.
And the other thing we do is
we give them credit for it.
And so for those researchers
that find those things,
we make sure that the world
knows that they did us
a favor, which helps them out
as they're building up their CVs
and looking to move
beyond academia.
We have a global network
to deliver our services.
And our customers of
the Cloud Platform
can also take advantage of this.
One of the other things that
we're particularly proud of
is that we believe that we've
provided a lot of leadership
in security innovation
across the industry.
And doing things like ensuring
that all the email that
comes out of Gmail
and comes into Gmail
is protected with
Transport Layer Security.
We've gone to HTTPS on
all of our services.
We were one of the
first providers
to get the ISO 27001
certification on our Google
Apps services, our SaaS offering
for collaboration applications.
And we have some other things
that we continue to do.
We recently put out--
or a couple years ago--
and we've done TLS on Gmail.
And we've recently
published a safe email site
which has identified the
service providers who are not
taking advantage of TLS.
And the interesting
side effect of that
is that some service
providers, who will go unnamed,
quickly upgraded their
services once we shined
a little sunlight on that.
So let me shift gears
here just a moment.
If you're thinking
about IT security
or you're thinking
about your services,
you're thinking about using a
vendor, what kinds of things
are you worried about?
So I'm going to take a couple
moments here and just give you
guys a taste of the threat
model or the environment
that we're thinking about.
And also what we've learned
from a lot of customers
that we've talked about.
And just in case you're
curious about this,
this is the crew at our
data center in Finland.
They're getting out.
Getting a little sunshine here.
So who are you going
to worry about?
Here's the spectrum of
folks that we worry about.
Hackers.
We worry about-- if
we're a customer,
we're worried about
the service provider.
We worry about
our own personnel,
and in the shoes
of our customers,
they can worry about
themselves as well.
And we also worry
about governments.
Let's dig in a little bit here.
So hackers.
So we have a lot of
mechanisms we've put in place.
As you can well imagine,
Google's a very large target.
And we have persistent
attacks going on.
It's been going on for years.
And the hacking community has
had very, very little success
in being successful
against Google.
But the interesting
thing is because we
do have such a wide footprint,
and we do see a lot of traffic
across the globe, it enables
us to get smarter and smarter
our countermeasures.
And we build those
things into our front end
services and the things
that face the internet.
And we learn about
a lot of threats.
And our customers get to take
advantage of those protections.
Well, what about us?
What about Google as
the service provider?
I already described our software
development process to you.
We also employ a least privilege
model in terms of access
to customer data,
which there are
VPs in the company that are
responsible for granting
that access.
And we also perform background
checks on our employees.
And we have a security and
privacy focused culture.
We have public information
on our investor site
that explains the
employee code of conduct,
which employees agree to when
they start employment with us.
And we refresh the privacy and
security information training
to our employees
on an annual basis.
And we do this top to bottom,
every employee in the company.
The other things that are
hallmarks of-- contrary
to what you might read
in the press and stuff--
is that as a customer
of Google, it's
very clear that
you own your data
and you are the
controller of that data.
Google operates in a
role of a data processor
and follows your instructions.
We're not sharing this
information with anybody else.
We're not using it for
our other businesses.
We use your data to provide the
service to you in the manner
that you want it.
As I said, we have
strict internal policies
that follow up on the privacy
and security training.
You know, I'll be really honest.
We've fired people
for violating that.
We've shown them the
door very quickly.
We take it very seriously.
And we also verify what we say.
We verify our policies.
We track and audit our
employees' activities
to make sure that we're
doing what we say we do.
As a customer, we provide you
control over your own data.
And so this is an example of
one of our user interfaces.
It's actually a
little bit dated.
But what I'm trying
to demonstrate to
you here is that
this is how we give
the control to the customer.
They control the access.
They control who uses it.
They control which
services are being used.
And so all of that
control is placed
in the hands of customers.
We do have a customer
support organization
that'll help you out if you
run into trouble with that.
But you are using
these resources
and controlling them yourselves.
Let's talk about governments.
And this becomes very
interesting in that-- I don't
know if it really applies
as much to the media
and entertainment
industry as it does some
of the other industries,
but we always
have customers
that are concerned
about governments
getting access to data
that's stored in our cloud.
And so a couple
things about that.
One is you may or
may not be aware,
but Google was the
first to publish
what we call a government
transparency report.
And so we are
publishing information
about all the
information requests
we get from the US
federal government
and other governments
around the world.
In our terms of service--
or in our agreements
with the customers--
our customers
are responsible for dealing
with government requests.
And it's our policy to
make sure that whoever's
making that request really
understands that, and really
interfaces with the customer.
And in the situations where
we were that doesn't happen
and we can't do that, unless
we're compelled by law,
it's also our policy to make
sure that the customer is aware
that that activity's going on.
And we push back on
that to make sure
that it's very
appropriately legal when
those types of things do happen.
We're also Safe
Harbor certified.
And what that means is
that enables us to comply
with European privacy law.
And we can present that
to our European customers
so that they understand that
and gives us legal standing.
And you don't have to
just take our word for it.
This is last year's scorecard,
presented by the Electronic
Frontier Foundation.
They do an annual
survey that they
call "Who's Got
Your Back?" where
they rate the various vendors
in terms of how they're
dealing with handling the
privacy of their customers'
information.
And as you can see in the
middle of the slide there,
we scored very well with them.
The other thing that's
really interesting about this
is that we've
improved over time.
We haven't always gotten
the highest marks.
But the other thing that's
really nice about this
is that the Electronic
Frontier Foundation does
this on an annual
basis, but they also
adapted to the
changing environment.
And so they're
constantly pushing
on what they're
measuring everybody on,
so it's not just a static thing.
You have to pay attention to
what they're paying attention
to, and we try to closely.
OK, let's talk about compliance.
So not specific to
media and entertainment,
we do run a formal compliance
program for Cloud Platform.
And what we're trying
to do there is we're
trying to, in industry specific
terms, convey to our customers
across the broad
spectrum of industries
that were complying with
security and privacy standards
in those different industries.
And to that effect, we actually
use third party auditors
to attest to most of these
things where it's appropriate.
And so just from an
IT service provider
point of view, the SSAE
16 and the ISO 27001
are two very important standards
there, which we bring in.
We have our third
party auditor, which is
Ernst & Young, certified point.
They come in and do these audits
for us on an annual basis.
And we can provide
materials that back that up
and show the evidence
to our customers
that we're doing that.
And so this has served us very
well in some other industry
verticals.
ISO 27001 is a pretty rigorous
security and privacy standard,
focused mostly on IT security.
And there's 12
control areas there,
and we meet all of
those control areas
and can make the certificate
available to customers.
Based upon that,
we built upon that
and we're able to service
the health care industry
by complying with HIPAA.
And we comply with HIPAA.
And we'll meet the
contractual requirements
by providing a business
associate's agreement
to covered entities in
the health care space.
I know that sounds like
a lot of gobbledegook.
But what that means is that if
you are building a health care
application which has
patient data in it,
that data is covered
by the HIPAA laws.
And we can provide
an environment
that enables
customers to deliver
those type of applications
but be sure that the service
provider, us, is making
sure that that data stays
safe and private.
And we're backing that
up in the contract.
And in a very similar
vein, we support PCI DSS,
which is the payment card
industry's data security
standard.
We've certified the whole
platform against version 2.
And the reason it's
version 2 is at the time
we started the audit
on that, version 3
hadn't been ratified by the
payment card industry yet.
They did that work,
and we actually
have just completed
our 3.0 certification
and we're signing
certificates for right now.
So we're very shortly--
in fact, you're
the first people that are
hearing this right now,
because I got the
email this morning.
But we'll be making
some noise about that.
So for those folks in
the retail industry
and the people in
the banking industry
that are dealing with
payment card data,
we provide this assurance
that we'll safeguard
that information as well.
And they can use that to build
up their compliance story
with their auditors and
with their customers
that they need to do that with.
Very quickly, FISMA and FedRAMP.
These are US federal government
standards for government
to be able to take advantage
of information services.
We've done FISMA
where appropriate.
FedRAMP has replaced that,
and it's currently in process.
We have a goal of getting that
done by the end of the year
so we can tap into those
US federal government
customers that require that, and
the vendors that support them
as well.
And then I have
this dream out here
that I call the MPAA, which is
really relevant to this crowd.
And so I'll just give
you-- the story on this
is that we were paying
attention to it.
We looked at the first
version of the standard.
We were like, OK, this
isn't a really-- this
is pretty straightforward.
We think we can meet or exceed
the requirements in here.
But as we started to get to
know people in the industry
and stuff, and we learned
a little bit more,
everybody was kind
of like, well, OK,
that's not really-- that
doesn't do anything for us.
And not only did we
hear that, but I think
the MPAA heard that as well.
And so they've gone off.
And I think there's several
people in this room that
have been involved in that.
And we've talked
with some people
at the major studios
that have been
involved with that as well.
And they're retooling that.
And they're retooling that to
think more about cloud services
and some more complex
things that could be done.
And so we're anxiously awaiting
them to publish that standard,
so that we can communicate
an assessment against that
to everybody.
So that's an activity
that we have going on.
And hopefully that'll
be something--
it's probably not
the be all end all--
but hopefully
that'll be something
that helps you guys to
be able to take advantage
of our platform.
And our competitors'
platforms, to be quite frank.
Hopefully that will
give an inch away.
Aside from that, we are
also trying to figure out
and trying to navigate
the process of working
with the studios, and really
trying to listen and understand
what the studios
want to understand.
What we can do to demonstrate
to them that we're
meeting or exceeding their
expectations in terms
of protecting their data, and
enabling their vendors to take
advantage of our services and
protect their data as well.
And so we're hoping in
the not too distant future
that we'll be able to
tell a richer story there,
so that there can be
broader use of our platform
in your industry.
Very quickly, one of the
other things that we're doing.
We talked about having
these over 500 folks that
work on security at Google.
We've built up a
pretty rich tool set
inside of our
security organization
that we use on our own products.
And one of the things that
I'm in the process of doing
is I'm in the process
of commercializing
some of these products.
And this is an example of the
first one that is coming out.
This is called Cloud
Security Scanner.
What this does is
this is a tool that
works in conjunction with
applications that are developed
on Google App Engine.
And it basically will scan
that for common web development
vulnerabilities cross-site
scripting errors, DOM problems.
And this is a tool
we use on our own.
And all products that
we launch to the web
have to pass through this tool
or they can't get launched.
And so what we've done
is we've made this
available to our customers.
It's currently in beta.
It's available in the
developer's console.
And you can run it against
your own applications,
and you get feedback on it.
And you can fix the bugs.
And part of what we're
trying to do here
is make our platform
a really logical place
to deliver safe and
secure applications,
and let you guys take
advantage of years of expertise
we have in dealing with that.
So lastly, what I
want to convey here
is let us worry
about the security,
so that you guys can innovate
and take advantage of that,
and take off and really
focus on what you want to do.
Focus on creative things.
Focus on innovative software,
innovative applications.
And let us help you with
the security side of things.